nick and i were kind of hoping that we
would be the biggest hollywood power
couple in the room tonight you know for
once
but uh
i see someone invited them
come on comedy's finest nick offerman
and megan mullally brought the charm
while hosting last night's film
independence spirit awards indie stars
and a-listers pick elaine you greedy
maybe megan will start with a monologue
and i will
do an assortment of streaking passes
looks like nick wasn't kidding around
and although clothes were optional for
mr offerman the stars still brought the
flare to santa monica kristen stewart
and chanel andrew garfield giving us
color in valentino newly single julia
fox rocked her signature black eyeshadow
and stunning and gucci maggie gyllenhaal
who dominated the spirit awards the
spirit award
for best director goes to
maggie gyllenhaal maggie jillian all for
the last daughter the lost daughter
[Applause]
and while backstage maggie lets us know
if a return to acting is in the cards
after her award sweep really where my
mind is right now is writing and
directing yes i that's what i'm thinking
about and that's where it gets me
hot
the stars came together they showed
their solidarity and support for the
people of ukraine we'd like to take a
moment to send our best wishes
to those affected by the war in ukraine
and all unjust conflict around the world
we stand for independence as a community
we stand for freedom of expression we
stand for humanity today we are
compelled to stand with the people of
ukraine they are risking their lives to
fight for those very things
we stand with the hundreds of thousands
of refugees fleeing this war both
ukrainians and those of other
ethnicities and nationalities who are
being denied safe harbor and as the
award show continued first-time winners
like best female lead taylor page were
overcome with emotion the day that i got
nominated for this award my grandmother
passed away mary lucille
and she would always say
i don't go back i'm here
so let's be here right now
and i'm here this is crazy
another first fx series reservation dogs
takes home two big accolades from the
spirit awards the best ensemble cast in
the new scripted series is the cast of
reservation dogs